Papapa welcome back to part four of
Detroit to become human last episode was
oh my geez
I keep getting comments from you guys
saying that I well I read them now
literally I published a video now I need
to be nice to Hank so I'm gonna try to
be nicer to Hank we're neutral right now
so there's a lot of weight good ways to
get on his good size chicken food that
seems great you want some chicken food
whose chicken feet
I'm literally recording my third video
today I'm just crunching it out like the
good old things literally might says
away tonight I have nothing else to do I
just feel like I should let you guys
know in case I sound different or if I'm
acting like a dumb not smart and
all right I'm in damn straight
hey won't read this
can I have hot dog chew Hank what is
your problem
yeah don't you ever do as you're told
look you don't have to follow me around
like a poodle I thought you liked us all
right we gotta get in his good side what
are we gonna do Rick what do you send me
a piece of plastic for a partner and I'm
dealing with it if you think we're gonna
be buddies
you're stupid as you look yeah I don't
look stupid I look honor that that that
that that that that that let me scan
that first huh hamburg carbohydrates
salt fat or no no no Hank you got it
Hank
that is sugar pineapple action sounds
good
don't leave that thing here not a chance
follows me everywhere some call me a
thing man give me some checking
I feel like it would be great to have an
Android and Ryan you could start like
gambling he doesn't want to talk about
God yeah can I get in on it okay he just
doesn't get it
you got a free meal didn't pay for your
berries a friend I scratch his back to
scratch his mind see your corrupt cop is
that it does include the length Bank
Android so much that must be yeah it
must be a reason let's talk about the I
should tell you what we know about
deviants you read my mind you yes
pickles on his burger motion occurs in
software of some androids which can lead
to them emulating your human emotion in
English please I was not that
complicated feel emotions they just get
overwhelmed by irrational instructions
which can lead to unpredictable behavior
emotions so we screw everything out the
androids aren't as different from us as
we thought
we can talk about them like it just came
- yeah yeah yeah why don't they make you
look so goofy and give you that weird
voice designed to work harmoniously with
humans both my appearance and voice were
specifically designed to facilitate my
integration well they're [ __ ] out
you ever dealt with deviance before mean
yeah and he almost shot me why would I
lie about that a few months back a
deviant was threatening to jump off the
roof of a little girl
so I guess you've done all your homework
right so everything there is to know
about me
and I know you graduated top of your
class you made a name for yourself in
several cases and became the youngest
lieutenant to Detroit I also know you've
received several disciplinary warnings
in recent years senator you spend a lot
of time in bars so what's your
conclusion and you can use a haircut
since then I think working with an
officer with personal issues is an added
challenge but adapting the human
unpredictability is one of my futures oh
I thought he was winking at him it's a
few blocks away I'll be in the car
well played Connor will play radio just
stopped out of nowhere David cage step
up your game literally you're out of
batteries or what I'm sorry I was making
a report to cyber life
wait what had just happened well do you
plan on staying in the elevator
no I'm coming he's so awkward I love
their interaction so what do we know
about this guy
not much just that a neighbor reported
that he heard strange noises coming from
this floor mat say nobody's supposed to
be living here okay
the neighbor said he saw a man hiding an
LED under his cap Christ if we have to
investigate every time somebody hears a
strange yeah right we're gonna need more
cops a hit rock hey were you really
making a report back there in the
elevator just by closing your eyes
correct [ __ ] I could do that this is
funny conspiracy about pigeons cuz you
never seen a baby pigeon right huh you
never you never seen a small page in so
the conspiracies by the pigeons are
created by CIA to spy on Elyse we need
reality they just stay in their nest
until they're grown up or at big enough
that's why
but I still find it funny I can tell me
more about CIA pigeons but some action
is coming now this looks so much like
heavy rain I wonder why I guess I should
go first I could be the tank you know
[Music]
hey more pictures this is the CIA
hideout where they build the pigeons
whoa
stinks my places you cannot have a look
at this
too much rain rains going solo okay
oh it's disgusting
you poor console players is this the way
you have to deal with a pity
makes me hate can't eat any food a
cancer Wow truly pathetic suspect okay
that must mean something oh that's cool
I can pass on you know fresh air
out of my way pigeon also did you know
you're not supposed to give pigeon right
all right ducks
you're not supposed to give ducks right
I forgot you know what don't listen to
me
can we tell who that is
it's led is in the sink my surprise it
was an Android no human could live with
all these [ __ ] pigeons you see Matt
to lick into Telugu blue blood
why didn't I like it that's the real
question look there you are again huh
nine-year-olds huh interesting
any idea whatever may come I never seen
nine-year-olds and you at the same time
written 2471 times it's the same sign
Ortiz's Android wrote on the shower wall
why are they obsessed with this sign
looks like mazes or something it's like
a math maybe obsessive-compulsive right
what is it me me keep flipping over
chairs like I don't like it I just don't
like I don't have to be okay with it
I wouldn't still thank you game I could
not I figure that out myself scan the
chair that's right it will say wooden
chair just in case just in case i'm
david cage and make video games but
they're like movies where is it David
it's a chair where is a saint
oh my god okay find cause of loud noise
maybe the birds
military jacket okay Artie it would make
sense for the military to use androids
anything right that's something your mom
does when you're in first grade
Rupert Travis or driver's license is
fake cool at least we didn't come from
but we have found the noise you have to
find the other one for some reason Alexa
we're
these are so lame where Oh recycled
paper reasonably moved okay
what's the conclusion oh okay all right
I get it
that's the thing on the window
I don't know it looks like a notebook
but it's indecipherable I guess who
keeps oh my god the birds are so
annoying I guess if you have to keep
finding the other let's just go up and
down
oh oh hey hey hey I don't need you judge
me I don't need your judgment I'm sure
you get suck in games sometimes - okay
don't judge me please
suspect was here recently hey he found
what an idiot he ran to the living room
after being traumatized by the chair
all right well why don't we check out
what he was trying to do rather on the
wall I guess he was doing the
spreadsheets and then he plopped over
the pigeon thing that made the noise
probably then substantial damage on the
pigeon cage it's got fingerprints
oh it's fecal matter
yucky ducky but
medal all right let's see what happened
I can't wait but I want to know is why
all the pigeons live there CIA that's
right that's right everybody you never
seen a baby pigeon so why is that CIA
wants to spy on us
they're robots to be fair like with all
the weeds expect documents I think they
have to be public after certain amount
of years there's there's experiments of
CIA trying to put microphones on cats
and they use the tail to put like the
antenna is awful and the thing was they
were completely useless because the cat
just wouldn't go where they wanted them
to go whoa that's not a pigeon are you
crazy it's a chase scene everybody all
right let's make sure we get this for
sure we hit up whoa that's cool O'Connor
my man all right what now oh I just this
is all Sun yes
fast but risky oh yeah we going fast
boys save you do the bad fest but risk
yeah I need it fast
give it to me fares directly back
directed but crown bring it on I'm kinda
ah ain't nothin a teacher
slide it jump yeah
Alexa this is epic go get her
you did the slide move I haven't done
that sand ever I never done that I
really want to do this like flowers
okay directly it's a fast but risk what
are you thinking huh woody
I was born for this and lived with this
I breathed this they made a quick time a
lot easier I remember they were quite
tricky and every or maybe I'm just a
really good epic gamer you see I can't
fail I'm too strong and too strong I'm
too powerful I will never say hey who
you calling me answer
come on
direct but crowded let's go baby be
quiet Lex I meant I meant that
whoo
where you going cuz where you going huh
get out of my way son
dissolving corn everybody
I can't we we gotta save Hank your
doofus your dingus no I had it we're
friends now nothin
thank you I'll take it you know what
I'll take it
I've been playing pug G randoms lately
just cuz people I do get recognized
sometimes but most of the times people
have no idea who I am which is really
nice it sounds so pathetic but like
everyone always Know Who I am
anytime I hang out and just some which I
don't mind but like sometimes it's nice
to just talk to someone with no clue who
you are you know what I mean sounds are
like intervenor
that's not what I mean it's more like
sorry it feels liberating who are you
fugitives just like you and I've been
really enjoying it especially if I make
a friend and they don't know who I am
I'm like okay
nineteen of us still in working order
the rest were damaged escaping their
masters many tried to reach Jericho few
succeed humans have little pity for our
kind this is Jericho it's a refuge for
those who don't want to be slaves
anymore you all have the thing in your
dingus then you knew that only an
Android could follow the trail didn't
you okay now the graffiti makes sense
like now I feel bad
if you could decide for the signs
because one of us trusted you enough to
give you the key I understand how you
feel but we have more freedom here than
you ever did
I came to Jericho looking for hope you
guys are just a bunch of crackheads here
mmm
you're lost oh it's handling the rest of
us you just hit me we didn't ask for
this all we can do now is deal with the
Ainu does it right away you're safe here
you can stay with us as long as you want
go and see Lucy she might be able to
help you do
saddle it No thank you mrs. dumpling
smells too disgusting crackheads sitting
around doing nothing
pathetic lowlife piece of garbage I
don't like it
are you losing more like are you Lucy
loser
yeah sit down
not decimas it
now it does meseta
show me my
[Music]
oh she can repair it I'll stop the
bleeding
[Music]
this snot is proceeding
drink this
it's a monster energy drinks mixed with
gvo you learn police powers unknown you
will be more powerful than you ever
imagined hey Amy to sculpt a that in a
gulp I don't know go piss
give me your hand why
okay this is not how you handle and you
lost it oh yeah you've seen hell and now
he'll lives in you
your heart is troubled a part of shadow
and a part of light
which will prevail
your choices will shape our destiny
you know how Hank said when he talked
sorry when Hank spoke to Connor before
at the at the food place he mentioned
that we don't they don't actually have
emotions they just have simulated
emotions so they're not real but for
humans our emotions are completely
technically simulated as well there's
really no difference about it everyone
well not everyone but a lot of people
see love for example as this mystic
unexplainable thing when really it's
just chemicals in our brain and you can
very easily be explained and also it's
not just a thing for humans it's not
like it's this impossible thing it's a
nice thing way to look at it though I
get it let's just say for 20 Hellyeah
diagnostic program isn't working
I don't think it would have anything
good to say anyway
what happened here he's got robots no
what no what if they wanted to have fun
I don't want to shut down
I don't wanna sit down
all right she wanted live all right we
just got to keep exploring he said I
bear all lit it on fire stupid peril
remember the barrel means hit a lot of
times I look back on like old PewDiePie
and I just cringe but it's also
wonderful it's something nice about it
well that's probably only before like
you before you were born
no I don't time stops
what's your name
Marcus
I was glad to meet you Marcus
oh I guess she got that was dark I
didn't mean to laughter yeah what an
awkward timing
okay this is pretty great
it's getting really nihilistic I don't
like it okay this part is pretty
depressing I think we should we should
get out of here oh my god is that a kid
Ike
can you get worse
here you have time with a dead kid what
the hell is this they threw him out when
they didn't want him anymore he was
living on the streets before we brought
him here they'll all shut down if we
don't find a way to help them to help
them we need blue blood and bio
components we salvage what we can from
those who shut down but there's never
enough good thing I just call it a down
a hole they won't we're slowly dying out
I can't be bothered letting more
bearable who are you guys then sorry I
stopped looking over here okay
do you read really didn't need to tell
me that cyber light warehousing docks
West Virginia house a plane
all right you having fun here oh my god
so creepy
I know where we can find spare parts
cyber life warehouse is in Detroit
Harbor they have everything we need the
docks are guarded you can't just walk in
there and take what we want humans will
never let us which is why we won't ask
permission we don't have any weapons and
even if you did none of us knows how to
fight we can steal what we need without
fighting we'll just get ourselves killed
maybe but it's better than waiting here
to be shut down I'm with you all right
you know it's not turtles but I like it
come on dude what are you okay maybe you
can get another shirt now to be Nick his
Phoenix four guys are lame you know at
least one person is sitting with me no
they're not
okay all right sorry you know what maybe
you know what that was me trying to
sympathize with you I'm sorry there's no
recovery from that
there's a lot of rain in this game yeah
all right let's go to the creepiest
building where you can find everyone how
we're feeling I'm gonna like this one
something up boy
let's go Ali boo-boo yeah I call her Ali
boom oh my god
like Oh who's asking
I was told you could help us I don't
know who told you that
you came to the wrong place I'm sorry
wait we really need your help
it's let go we'll negotiate for the
child you go the child states we go
welcome to chill a pedophile joke
everybody keep watching the video come
on don't be shy
okay this is epic he's got an ostrich
Luther would you be so kind as to take
these ladies coats Jesus Christ
oh don't be afraid of a big friendlier
Luther is just another Android that I
helped he keeps me company in this big
empty old house
Jesus Christ Luther looks like he could
squash alleys into a piece of paper and
I kind of want to see it in a pleaded
way make yourselves at home
how did you hear about me an Android on
the street he said you could help us
I see was an awful painting
it's got you must be working on Andrews
about her
she's human
and you want to find a safe place
somewhere you can start a new life
I hear Canada it's very lovely at this
time of year yeah I'm sure it's not
raining landscapes open spaces clean air
and no android' laws a great place for a
fresh start
yes tents
that's exactly what we want no of course
well I can help you but first we have to
get rid of your tracker tracker yeah all
androids are fitted with a tracking
device to locate them at all times I'll
remove yours and then you'll both be
safe come on follow me are we feeling
about this game wait for us in the
living room no she always stays with me
of course right this way everything we
need is in the basement the basement huh
yeah yeah yeah yeah the basement of
course of course who doesn't like a good
ol good old basement or where it's so
dead we're so good
me neither alleys okay listen that we
have no choice we have to trust him what
if he just turns out to be super nice I
needed somewhere discreet for my
machines removing trackers is illegal so
I opted for discretion over comfort I
hope the little one isn't too scared no
no she'll be all right that's good what
is she looking at it's a turtle
I bet you it's a turtle it's a turtle
what do you say this way please what's
gonna happen there what are we online oh
my god Alice I swear to God if you drop
my hand one more alright I'm just gonna
go just gonna go whoa what is this
half-life 2 if you could just bond over
there I need a drink after this episode
have you guys ever played a half-life 2
should warn you this could be quite
unpleasant such a great way such a good
game it's so disappointing a half-life
that he never came out sorry this
reminds me of the beginning you know
strange for some unknown reason the
trackers seemed to start working in
deviance that's why it's so hard to find
them hey hey
actually there's no reason to remove
your tracker let go
people believe what they want you
deviants are so naive they all come to
me expecting me to help them and I just
reset them keep them for my little
experiments child
lock it up I'll deal with it later a
deviant that wants to be a mother that's
that's so sweet I'm so deluded oh my god
this guide you I think it's time we put
you out of your misery
I don't really know how we're gonna get
out of this no not again oh there must
be something happening the dream there
must be something I can do it always
ends up the same way
tears and dissolution it must be
something I can do believe me you're
better off being raised and feeling
nothing no more pain no hope - keep him
and shave his stupid face almost at you
you don't hurt a lace only I can hurt
Alice meet me in the living room
yeah how
okay sure
it's only other way
okay I feel like we don't have a lot of
time so uh yeah well that didn't work
oh my god where
if you've moved
mmm
come on come on
what's my damn act
no I feel
[Music]
ah I wonder I could have gone it there
right
I would have hit there
damnit oh well I've decided that I you
know if I mess up I'm gonna keep it just
for the sake of tension it would be kind
of lame if I just go back all the time
yeah
sure I wanna okay that's great
he likes to play this creating monsters
okay demonetized thank you whoa that's
cool I mean that's awful
yeah
it's not that easy like don't be so mean
I didn't even do anything
hey you have tiny hands
oh shoot I forgot to call my parents
today see what you guys do I choose
gaming over my own family this is not
good
there's a ringabel
America vertigo
anything I can find
pastas dinner's ready
take it up to you
yes Luther
where is the dinner
sorry
that's his dinner potato chips nice a
matter of culture I like it yeah
wait is that I think I need to pay
attention
I want to look around just to make sure
we may be possibly unlock our memory you
know okay there's nothing really you
don't stop feeling so I can get my mind
of these yellow back people why the
still alive I don't know go think I mean
my back okay oh wait this is outdoors
yeah
remain with your own okay
[Music]
I guess he's upstairs right I don't
remember what he says I have no memory I
realize I'm extremely tired it's fun
though it reminds me like when I was
younger just like crunching at videos
really lame really takes me back man
I have such a strict schedule when I
shoot videos now like I have my set
working hours that I never go outside of
this feels really weird also especially
calling this work I guess but just set
it down on the table over there you
having fun here buddy
it's let go more like [ __ ] cow got them
potato chips on a silver tray this guy's
a legend
no that's the spaghetti scene again I
can bring carcass carcass carcass this
doesn't have any nipples that's lame
yeah there it is oh no no I can't
oh god no don't give me don't give me a
time thing to save a little girl you
sick bastard who is the little girl
remember remember okay okay okay I'm
huge I'm hastin I'm hating right now
what are you are you it Syme best joke
ever made everybody thank you
Oh we'd remember him now perfect
everyone just smokes that stuff
[Music]
okay that helps
I hate how it's timed I hate time stuff
okay just keep going you got this
good good job you just weights the time
on this or something here
yes perfect
No
my name is Cara Yosh
yeah we probably shouldn't go in there
okay so we remember her now that's good
this is thing with his game they always
mix so many genres from like horror to
thriller to suspense to love I love it
love you babe
ain't never gonna stop loving you
[Music]
okay I will go use Dunga
what are you doing nameless you were
you're in a bathtub oh she's probably in
here hey how you doing buddy
Detroit residents were disturbed by we
don't have time
a lot of small stuff like that seemed to
matter in this crazy where is she is
stressing me out man
here's Alice thank God thank God
never thought I'd care about this stupid
girl
we have to go follow me and don't weed
anyways okay
oh now we just got to make sure we can
escape
okay all right bring me the child yes
I'm finished you go fix a little slack
go
of course they have to give that weird
one a Eastern European name
this is a terrible hiding spot
oh god I can't take this uh okay
is in here
door slam and brown
he's lost yeah this is epic
oh my god Alexa this is epic let's go
[Music]
oh my god he has a shoddy he's got his
lights goes out of shaadi I went over
the door I don't know crazy right front
door are you kidding me
no ha ha
too slow hey that's right take a lamp
huh ha ha ha
bet that was a spirit lamp loser since
of lamps let's go let's go oh god he's
Alice you Dunga go Alice you just go oh
my god Alexa this is bad you should you
should look after your house
not this time whoa get out of my way
okay this is epic Alexa this is epic
yeah nipple girl get him
[Music]
he became a deviant in just the right
time
thank you convenience zombie horde that
I thought I burned down
I didn't want to hurt you and programmed
me to obey Him I know that it's okay
when I saw the little one risk our life
to save you
it was like opening my eyes of the first
time
finally I could see
I know you have no reason to trust me
after what I did oh he's coming with it
I could protect you
you
all right
all right you know yeah I trusted slight
go and you know it didn't turn out so
bad so yes
I feel like that's a perfect ending I
try to make them an hour it's a little
less but I think it would be silly to
keep going now that was a really cool
story really really enjoy that so Luther
joins regardless it seems like oh
actually never mind never mind
I was wrong cool
that was really fun another successful
chapter hope you guys enjoyed another
episode I'm not recruiting anything more
today thank you guys for all the support
Rob you and bye